hey have you ever felt like all the
motion design out there is the same that
what you see on social media is all
there is but let me tell you that is
just a misconception motion design is an
ever-evolving field and there are
countless Styles techniques and
approaches to explore from traditional
2D animation to futuristic 3D renders
the possibilities are endless so if
you're feeling uninspired by what you
see on social media don't give up take
some time to dig deeper and find the
incredible range of motion design Styles
and techniques that exist you might just
discover something new and exciting that
Sparks your creativity and pushes you to
design something truly unique
foreign